after just an amazing struggle fabi it
looked like you went for it from the
very beginning take it on c3 b4 go for
it open up the lines it looked like you
came in with uh
blood in your eyes
no i think it might have been the other
way around because he uh
he surprised me he i mean he's an expert
in the f3 nimzo but he hasn't played it
in a long time i didn't expect it so at
the start i was
wasn't sure which line to play and i
picked a line that level and played
against me um
it's a very good line
um
and
like you can't get blown away with prep
i mean i actually did a lot of work on
this line for the candidates because i
was playing this with white
but i don't know what
where we like left theory because after
ed5 i didn't realize this was a
possibility i i knew cd5 was um
was the main move i actually played this
way against levon and he didn't take on
d5 he played knight h5 first
which is also interesting but but maybe
not
um and then bishop e3 f f5 it turns into
a mess
but ed5 um
yeah i expected cd5 knight h5 and it's a
very very complicated
uh struggle okay ed5 i i didn't think
this would be the best move
um
were you happy to see this position at
all
i wasn't displeased with it i mean
like i thought this this is a pretty
healthy line for black and
and it is very complicated things can
things can go really wrong for white too
because there's almost no development i
think things can also go positionally
wrong for black because if white gets g4
and ig3 then black starts getting
um positionally crushed
uh so that's why i played f5 because
like knight d7 g4 i was that was my
first intention
queen h4 king g2 and like i have this 95
stuff but he always has knight g3 and
i didn't see any way to continue the
attack
and it can just get really really bad
for black if uh if i don't have
something concrete
so i thought f5 is a is probably the
best move
and
stopping the g4 thrust stopping and also
preparing that for myself so i
i really cram uh
cram down on his position if he allows
that
so knight f4 was expected i could play
queen h4 but i didn't think it was very
good i mean it wins an exchange in a
pawn
but
the problem is i take on h1
and queen e2 and my position besides
speeding up an exchange is uh
i wasn't sure like it
uh
my queen's not getting trapped i even
have a move like g5 here
uh g596 f4 or something like this but i
couldn't quite make sense of it it just
looked like
too much of a mess and i didn't want to
go for it
but i did spend some time considering
this
so i thought okay take g5 as normal
and
[Music]
yeah i wanted to play f4 first to stop
him from f4 but then after g4
i thought he'll have g4 my bishop
doesn't have a place to go that's at
least the reason why i did this um
and then he he plays b3 bishop b2
eventually
but maybe this is better than what i did
it was like it was so difficult to
decide on because each move
each move we both have a lot of choices
and and it's a very murky position
so yeah i i was very happy with my
position though i saw this whole f4
stuff and i got
i got very optimistic in this position
if you made
the engine suggested g4 with knight e4
what was your consideration about this
line i didn't like this so much um
if he plays bishop d3
like i see the bar says i'm much better
but
but i can't imagine why i would be much
rookie 8 b3
do i play knight c3 at some point is
that bishop between knight c3
that's the only thing i can imagine and
then
i guess i'm in time to support the pawn
otherwise it just doesn't really make
much sense i thought
okay
but uh yeah maybe this was much better i
don't know i i was i was actually
uh kind of
um thinking that i have a very strong
attack here so i might have
mis-evaluated it
yeah it looks like he's a peter peters
fiddler came in and said why did you
play
bishop g6 before
the move rookie eight
i didn't realize h3 was an option and i
thought if rook e8
uh instead of queen g7 or instead of the
senate bishop g6 if you can go yeah just
one more move this move was possible
also yeah rookie yet i thought he'll
play bishop e3
i
i didn't see how to continue here
because now bishop g6 he's the one who
gets the trade on f8 first misplacing
one of my pieces so i didn't see the
next move maybe there's queen e5 but i
didn't uh
i preferred bishop g6 because i didn't
realize h3 was an option at all
and and that was kind of unfortunate
because after h3 his king finally gets
somewhere
to safety yeah
like relative safety his king gets to h2
but his bishop still can't move he's a
queen e5 so he's still kind of stuck
but yeah uh he he shocked me with
queenie too i was i mean i couldn't
what was your main move for him exactly
at this point we had this bishop before
you yeah that was our main line and did
you have a
plan for the bishop before yeah so i
spent all all my time on this with
rookie four and uh bishop g3
right this isn't yeah and if rookie won
then he takes on g6 rookie one and my
king is actually in
exactly oh no oh sorry he takes that g6
and then
yes uh that was our line too yeah but i
thought that here i would have a way to
bail out um
that was the line we we looked at fabio
sorry
oh how was i going to bail out here
no i was already not playing for an
advantage so
so what was i going to do um
i think rookie 3
rook e3 okay
queen do you like i can't
i mean so much happened after this point
that i already forgot everything i
intended here
understood
that time pressure you guys were in he
got up from the board
before you played when you when he
played queen e2
he got him on the board and walked away
did you even were you even aware that he
was away from the board you were so
focused because knight f6 must have been
just going off in your mind but he
wasn't sitting at the board to give you
any clue as to whether or not this was a
good move that he had overlooked
well i don't look at my opponents to
figure out what the i understand but he
but he actually got it from the board
even i mean yeah move queenie too but he
sometimes does that so i didn't
if i noticed i didn't read much into it
um
and i realized that i have basically no
time i have to
um
to really ration my time because we had
like 15 moves left and i have like three
or two minutes
um
so i knew that i really had to
economize with my calculations i
couldn't
couldn't
spend any time you know trying to figure
out details i had to basically pick a
line and calculate it as best i could um
so i didn't look at any movement size
906 once i saw that move i just
i just spent my time calculating it and
it looked good um and i don't know why
he went for this uh
because
i mean queenie two just doesn't make a
whole lot of sense to me
uh i don't feel like i'm any worse after
that
um
it looked like he just overlooked
everything that happened maybe maybe
yeah maybe he missed knight f6 uh i
don't know if he it was still unclear he
could also sack the queen there
that's what i actually thought he wanted
to do
exactly if i could just draw you to the
board i thought that he first of all he
spent
two thirds of his time his remaining
time playing the move queen e2 you
answered the most direct
and
we thought that his intention had been
to sacrifice his queen with bishop takes
g6 rook takes e2 bishop f7 and when he
didn't do it just just one oh i'm sorry
after after bishop 7 i was going to play
king g7
so oh sorry after you know
the automatic recapture but king g7 okay
if bishop d6 is knight e4 i thought uh
looks like his pieces are suddenly
hanging in midair now i see that he has
bishop fade but i don't think it works
uh and gf6 now king of southern my king
is very safe behind the pawn so this is
what i was having and then
my i started to pick up pawns i i
thought that i would be better okay um
it i still expected this because it
doesn't
look clear-cut i still can't really
attack his king because he just defends
g2 and his bishop controls his diagonal
so
so the only way for me to
play for an advantage here is basically
to try to collect as many pawns on the
queen side as i can right um but did you
feel that he was going to play bishop g6
when he played queen e2 as well i
thought it has to be the idea exactly
okay so yeah there was a logic glitch
then when did you know it was all over
at what point did you think i got this
okay i mean i thought this should be
winning
because i i like instead of rook f6 i
have so many
i it still seemed very difficult to me
okay because d6 is so weak
and his king is still very safe
but somehow he's pinned in all sorts of
ways and i thought rook f6 is not not
the only move so usually if you have a
wide choice one of the moves is probably
good i mean queen f6 is also very
very logical and probably fine
okay
yeah
so
big win for you winning with the black
pieces against a player like chakriar
no easy feat you got two rounds to go
you're half a point out of first are you
thinking what are you thinking right now
yeah this was a really important win um
i mean
because charcoal is very dangerous with
white uh last time we played he in
classical in bucharest he beat me
um
and also because we are sort of
i mean he's he's far ahead of me and
grant us tour points but we are sort of
competing for
maybe third place i i don't maybe he's
too far ahead of me but
uh but there is still some outside hope
by the way he's playing and not the way
you're playing
anything could happen right now it's not
much of a difference i guess
plus two and minus one i don't know
because i really had to make some make
up such a such a deficit
um
but
at least this gives me hope i mean if i
had drawn
um
and and also maxim who is like the
nearest to me is starting to win all
those games
um
[Music]
this this was an important win
indeed what what are your thoughts about
tomorrow's game between maxima and
wesley
um who's is wesley playing white again
or is
maximus white okay he gets the double
um
i mean wesley is really tough to beat
so i
i would probably
place my bet on a draw
also they both seem like they're in good
shape and usually if two players are
playing pretty consistently
um and also i'm not sure that either of
them has any reason to risk i don't i
mean maximum is in first place
wesley is leading the grandchildren i
think they're they might even both be
almost satisfied with kind of risk-free
oh man said he's he's gone for it yeah
no i i'm he's not going to take a quick
draw but he he might
also not take
extraordinary risks it could be a 50 000
game but we'll say we'll leave that to
maxim's thoughts what about you against
peter tomorrow
i i haven't thought about this game
i still need to kind of i mean playing
with like two minutes for for most of
the game is uh is pretty it really you
know freeze your nerves so
first i want to just calm down and uh
and hopefully tomorrow i can play well
you had three seconds on your clock at
one point by the way uh alejandro was
crying and screaming for that so let's
avoid those kind i think that was queen
takes me too right right i just wanted
to make sure i'm not blundering any like
bishop somewhere bishop g5 or you know
right got you all right well
calm yourself get some rest and we'll
see you tomorrow
thank you fabie congratulations and
after that